اصدرت منظمه هيومن رايت سبوتش تقريرها
الثانويه لاوضاع حقوق الانسان في العالم
خلال عام
2022 وبدا التقرير بمقدمه اشارت الى ان
السلسله الطويله من ازمات حقوق الانسان في
هذا العام تنتهي الى استنتاج ان السلطه
الاستبداديه المطلقه تفضي الى معاله
الانسانيه
بالتزاماتهم الحقوقيه وان اداره
خففت انتقاداتها للانتهاكات والاستبداد
رغم تعاهدتها كما اضفت مقدمه التقرير ان
المعايير المزدوجه لم تقتصر على القوه
العظمى بل على كثير من الحكومات التي لم
تلتزم بتعهداتها قال ان هناك مساحه اكبر
لتظهور تحالفات واصوات قياديه جديده تعمل
وعلى تغيير واقع حقوق الانسان
هذا واعتبر تقريبا منظمه ان ملف اوكرا
يحمل مثالا ايجابيا حيث ان من الايجابيات
تفعيل النظام حقوق الانسان العالمي
لمحاسبه روسيا وتعليق عضيتها في مجلس حقوق
الانسان واستدراك التقرير وان على
الحكومات ان تفكر كيف سيكون الوضع اذا قام
المجتمع الدولي ببذل جهود لمحاسبه بوتن
قبل ذلك في عام 2015 على انتهاكاته في
سوريا او القمعي في روسيا
لاوكرانيا
صعد الى قمه الصاعده الى قمه اجنده حقوق
الانسان في العام 2002 2020
ايضا الى ان الامم المتحده وجدت عمليات
قتل غير قانونيه للمدنيين وجرائم حرب
كررتها القوات الروسيه
بعدد هائل كما ظهرت معلومات عن اساءه
القوات الاخرانيه معامله اسرى الحرب
واعدامهم باجراءات موجزه بما قد كيلو
جريمه حربه انا كلا من اوكرانيا وروسيا
استخدمت المدارس للهجمات العسكريه ما ادى
لتضررها كما استخدم كلا او كلا البلدين
قذائف فعنقوديديه في الهجمات واشار
التقرير بترحيب الشهاده بترحيب اوروبا
بملايين اللاجئين الاخرانيين لكنه قال انه
يظهر المعايير الاوروبيه المزدوجه في
معامله طالبه اللجوء من بقيه الجنسيه